well Jim Comey and Adam Schiff have been
all over television recently desperately
trying to act in their own interest as
always they're trying to downplay the IG
report from last week and how it exposed
FBI to lies and particular lies to a
FISA Court that allowed them to spy on
an American citizen Carter page
according to Jim Comey it was not a big
deal at all compared to a lot of other
malfeasance currently going on at the
FBI none of which he would describe in
any detail but the FISA Court appears to
disagree today in a rebuke even the New
York Times called quote extraordinary
the FISA Court accused the FBI of
repeatedly misleading it the court in
the Carter page case the court gave the
FBI until January 10th to propose
changes to his procedures to prevent
future abuses Francie Hanks is a former
federal prosecutor knows a lot about
this process she joins us francy thanks
so much for coming on so when the when
the Court itself attacks the FBI for
subverting the process at that point
there's really no denying what happened
is there
well no Tucker it completely destroys
the Democrats argument that there was
anything partisan at all in the
complaints that President Trump and
president Trump supporters and the
Republican Party were making early on
all the way last year early last year
and even before that talking about this
FISA warrant against Carter page and
talking about being spied upon while
people are trying to make much of the
fact that President Trump said his wires
were tapped it looks like maybe Trump
Tower wasn't actually tapped but you had
confidential human sources run by the
FBI against three different members of
the Trump campaign including one against
whom not a single criminal allegation
had been made no one's even talking
about that but what's extraordinary I
ask you to pause right there how can you
wiretap an American citizen who hasn't
even been accused leave aside credibly
accused but accused at all of a crime
how can that happen I you know it's it's
a mystery to me Tucker they sent a
confidential human source with a
recording device of some kind against a
quote high-level campaign official that
we still don't know who it is but we do
know that they've
mitad that there was no crime alleged to
help don't we know who it is like what
an outrage is that what what would be
what would be the pretext for keeping
that secret from the rest of us well I
suppose it could be to protect them from
being accused of something that they
didn't do but at this point it seems to
me that for full transparency we need to
know who it was so we might know who
recorded them you know honestly at this
point you feel like we need full
transparency to anyone who stands in the
way of it should be charged with a
felony and prosecuted at least as
vigorously as I don't know Roger stone
has been prosecuted right well it's true
Tucker and what the rosemary Collier
what judge Collier did today in this
FISA order was so significant and so
extraordinary
she took the Inspector General's
conclusions she called the FBI on the
carpet she labeled what they had done
wrong and a violation of the court and
said that they were not credible in
their allegations and that they had to
in a very short order explain to the
court what they were gonna do to make
sure it never happened again and
significantly she also mentioned an
order of the FISA Court that was
apparently promulgated just a week or so
ago that was top-secret so none of us
have seen it and she's ordered the
Department of Justice to allow it to be
declassified so we can see what buys a
court wants keep in mind it's so-called
liberals who are defending all this crap
there's nothing liberal about them
they're authoritarians back with
corporate power and you should be afraid
of them I am Francie great seeds name
thank you thanks Tucker